dr bright is to be consistently reminded  that if what he is doing involves doing  something wrong it is not the right  thing to do sure the foundation could  always use more funding however that  does not mean it's acceptable for dr  bright to organize a massive heist at a  luxury casino recruiting a variety of  retired criminals to carry out a  detailed multi-step plan of espionage  deception and robbery it might have  worked out in the ocean's film series  but it is not the sort of behavior the  foundation condones in the real world we  live in a society damn it there are  rules we have to follow sure we do a  great deal of possibly unethical human  testing resulting in thousands of  d-class deaths every year but we have to  draw the line somewhere